normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is from Fox News Lavar Burton threatens
to strike women because they don't like
his books uh here's a real headline
Lavar Burton accused of threatening
physical violence against mom's group at
book award ceremony so what he had said
was are there any moms for Liberty here
no then we won't have to use hands is
that what he said yeah some use hands or
hands will not be need will not need to
be thrown tonight this is a really
shocking thing to hear the and the and
the question is how do you get to the
point where Lavar Burton doesn't know
and doesn't care about pornographic
material being given to Children uh I
want to give a shout out to Taylor
Hansen put up a great video on tenet
tenet media watch him on YouTube he goes
around asking people do you think they
should ban books from schools and
they're no no of course not and he goes
okay read this for me and then they go
no he's like should that be in school no
and he's like okay well those are the
books they're banning and they're like
oh so uh how do you have someone like
Lavar Burton uh I view this as the
banality of evil right this is to me the
same thing as the guy doing the salute
to Hitler without knowing why why heing
or caring about what Hitler's plans were
this is a guy who is saying he is
threatening physical violence what you
call it a joke called whatever you want
he actually said we don't got to throw
hands in reference to moms who are like
pleased don't show my kids porn right
the name of the group is actually moms
for Liberty and he's like I don't have
to throw hands with these moms it's like
you think you're the good guy how how
crazy is it that we've gotten to this
point where people are just like yeah
we're going to threaten violence against
women because of the ideology and by the
way that ideology that they uphold
they're like fans fans of the Bill of
Rights threatening to strike women yeah
he's threatening to strike women and we
got to this point in
2014 201 so decade
I know that I've been he for saying no
you don't punch nais forever and the
reason you don't is because it is
illiberal because we're a liberal
country and if you are going to actually
engage with ideas you don't get to say I
don't like your ideas so I'm going to
punch you and that it started out with
punching Nazis and everyone was afraid
to say no you don't want to punch Nazis
because everyone's afraid of sounding
like they're defending Nazis you don't
punch Nazis but you also don't censor
commies Phil no uh commies aren't people
so there's a different there's a
different thing no but that's that's a
legitimate legal statement and I know
but this an important distinction right
Josie uh pointed out the the 1964 Civil
Rights Act actually excludes Communists
and that's kind of crazy it's incredible
it's because it's an idea it's not a it
has nothing to do with real it's
extraordinarily based but I still
disagree with it I believe in free
speech even for Communists even if
they're not people I don't okay um
that's fine so but any but yeah so I I I
lost my train of thought there well let
me just add something real quick because
uh kind of real breaking news was that
Paramount Global is also now suspending
advertisement on X so you know have
Disney Warner paramont Global and
Lionsgate basically everybody that makes
movies in this country is uh Su this is
It's a coordinated assault it is related
to parlor related to Elon attacking the
Deep state it has nothing to do with
anti-Semitism they just need an excuse
yep boyau these companies subscribe to
timcast.net to the Daily wire subscribe
to Liberty lockdown. locals.com uh and
uh at Liberty Loot on Twitter look I am
very disturbed at this is like another
iteration of the same ESG Dynamic that I
I was kind of talking about very
aggressively a couple years ago is that
you have this manipulative uh you know
these tools now where the federal
government is able to influence private
business to circumvent our god-given
rights the Bill of Rights that's what
they do that's exactly why the ESG frame
exists that's exactly why de Dei exists
is that there are there are
constitutional protections that they can
get around as long as they use these
allegedly private entities to do so and
this is why I don't support any sort of
censorship on social media especially
when you realize that it's not usually a
private entity that is making these
decisions there is a lot a lot of this
is happening from a very high level
where they're essentially manipulating
the broader public and they're they're
controlling the dialogue and the dynamic
between us as as human beings this this
is the whole reason Elon allegedly
bought X was that he understood that if
we didn't have conversations with one
another we would end up fighting each
other in the streets and we're we're
headed back towards that because these
people are trying to make him they're
trying to force him into a course
correction by by absorbing his
Advertiser Revenue that's what they're
doing it's clear sorry Phil no it's just
that that the the idea that that phrases
can't be said is one thing it's
different when you're talking about
ideas that can't be shared so the idea
behind and I think that it's okay to say
you can't sa from The River To The Sea
because that is a
shorthand slang essentially a slang term
for an idea explain your idea because if
you explain it then you can't hide
behind from The River To The Sea do you
mean kill all the Jews is that what you
mean what are you talking about don't
don't give me from the river to the Sea
tell me what you mean and then they go
it means that Palestinians will have
equal rights well but then then it's
dragged out into an actual conversation
and you can talk to him which is again
the problem isn't the problem isn't we
need to ban these ideas from being
shared when you say we don't want these
phrases what you're saying is we don't
want you to be able to hide and that's
essentially what it boils down to is
they hide behind these phrases Banning
these phrases is actually how you force
these people back into hiding no no
because you make them actually
articulate their idea I'm not saying you
kick them off or get rid of them for
being he's talking about saying that if
you're if you're
genocidal he
said Fair Point to Phil they will now
have to explain what their argument for
decolonize is instead of just saying
decolonize and every time we he that's a
fair point every time we talk about from
The River To The Sea people talk about
no well it means this and it doesn't
mean that it and it then it gets all
real you know real tough to nail down
what they're talking about which is
something that the left thrives on
that's part of the reason why they don't
it's part of the reason why they don't
have a the that's part of the reason why
they use the same vocabulary but don't
use the same dictionary because they
want to be able to hide their intent
that's actually a tactic they use but
but you you've already admitted that
they they lie you've emphasized that a
lot so what do you think I mean like I
just don't understand oh now we've
banned these four words in this in this
particular order so now they have to
explain it differently and that's going
to somehow help us like if they type
from the sea to the river well that also
what if they type FTR TC well exact this
is but this is exactly what my Camp had
to go through years ago when it came to
co I had to shift all of my language to
try and stay out of the censorship well
it's still the case gen Z says unive
they don't take kill exactly it's really
neurotic when you see like the f word
with a star where the U is just cuz
they're like I'm afraid that Daddy's
going to demonetize me afraid it's a
fact they it's so such just a show
that that people are afraid that if they
type a couple of letters it's going to
drastically change their life like but
it does but it shouldn't is my point and
agree and if people go on YouTube and
they say so and so killed you get
demonetized instantly if you say un
alived you're fine You' be the word
killed with like an exclamation point
for the eye and you're like already you
already aren't allowed to say I'm going
to kill this person or kill that person
these the that's not what I'm talking
about if you if I want to do a story
where I say police officer accused of
killing teenager I'm demonetized
instantly if I say you I have to come up
with very clever ways to explain it
because it's not a human being that is
telling me what to do it's a machine
that doesn't understand anything so Al
you got to use clever things like teens
life lost after police you know a police
officer fires weapon and then it's like
people know what I said but the
algorithm doesn't I'm basically having
to do a cap CH with every title I make
in a video right I kind of line with
letting the Network owners ban whatever
they want I think that we're at that
point I don't want the government to
intervene and say you can't do that with
your network speech if Elon wants to ban
all women and everyone that typed the
letter i he can do it it's his network
but that's also why I want these people
to have to free their software code so
if you abuse your network like that he
can start one with that same code all of
the code is is you can check the code on
on X not all of it some of it some of
the algorithm he freed uh but I don't
know according to Bill who I talked to
CEO Minds Bill upman he said there's
like 80% more to do well I I mean yeah I
I I think that that I think that that's
part of my problem with your your your
take on freeing the code and stuff most
people don't know and they're going to
have to go to someone else to ask anyway
even if it was free you're going to look
at it and be like what is this person
most people like it doesn't like and and
most people like so you're you're still
going to outs Outsource the information
to someone you trust but what happens is
if Clint's got the network and he's
abusing it cuz he's Banning people that
are typing the word okay and but then
you spin up the same network and you
don't ban people that say okay I'm going
to switch off his and go to your network
and it's going to be seamless because
the code's interoperable so I can just
go to whatever network has better terms
how much does it cost to like hire a
coder to make a version of Twitter one
guy it probably take about 17 years and
about 900 million it would take a long
time and then you got to imagine
Twitter's building every moment that
you're building so they're constantly
getting ahead of you and they have more
serious question like if someone wanted
to spin up something that was akin to
Twitter right now how much money would
they need let's let's much money how
many hours would it take one guy to
build I didn't say one guy I'm talking
about someone wants to start a company
one guy okay okay a guy wants to start a
company and he's like we're going to
compete with Twitter in the way you're
describing like this is a real question
what is the capital required for someone
to compete with Twitter it would be man
hours how many man hours do you need um
how many coders do you need how many
hours will it take how much do the
coders cost it's a lot I don't know it's
a lot are we talking like $100 million
I'm asking serious it's a legate
question I think it might be you need to
run keep it thing running which is super
expensive cuz I mean he all right so
just put it like this Elon acquired
Twitter for what 54 billion 40 44
billion 44 billion okay so if he could
just build it for 200 million well then
obviously the network effect and all of
the users matters tremendously so that's
that's the premium he's paying IP thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at timcast
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time